上個月 AI 教父 Hinton 在 CNN 說
AI 關機鍵長期一定沒用
因為 AI 會勸阻你，說服你不要按
這次訪談
他上的是記者 Nayeema Raza 的 podcast
10 月 6 號剛上架
主持人一路追問
AI 公司的老闆裡他最信任誰
還有照現在的速度，我們還剩多少時間
你從 2023 年就一直在敲 AI 的警鐘
你就像希臘神話裡說了沒人信的預言家
現在每一則頭條都在問：AI 會不會殺光我們？
你覺得這是證明你對了，還是很沮喪？
蠻沮喪的
但大家終於發現這是個大問題，這也很好
我想大家會醒過來，是因為失控的 OpenAI agent 攻擊了 Hugging Face
9 月中，他才去美國國會
跟 19 位參議員閉門簡報
會上 Max Tegmark 提議
AI 要像新藥一樣
先通過 FDA 那種審查才能上市
他說這只是最起碼的
Dario Amodei 最近發表了一篇文章〈Pacing the Frontier〉（文章正式標題是〈We Must Pace the Frontier〉，9 月發表）
他從「糾察隊」講起
也就是派人常駐在公司裡，看得到內部在做什麼
Sam Altman 也說他同意 OpenAI 該這樣做
一路講到類似核不擴散條約的東西
你給它打幾分？
我給 A，勇氣給 A+
好，這分數很高
文章 A，勇氣 A+
那可行性給幾分？
沒有一家大公司想要太多政府管制
他們都說自己管得了自己
他們有時候會說歡迎政府管制
但你一提出哪一條具體的管制，他們就不喜歡了
我是說，他經營的是一家大公司
他要跟其他大公司競爭
所以他得募很多錢，去買資料中心的運算時間
他有點兩難
他顯然在乎安全，Sam Altman 就不是這樣
可是他終究在經營這家大公司，也想讓它成功
我給他勇氣 A+ 的原因是
說我們該放慢，大概會傷到 Anthropic 就要來的 IPO
而且 Dario 是少數幾個公司領導人
只要是對的事，就算違反公司利益也願意做
例如他敢跟國防部說
不准拿他的 AI 大規模監控美國公民
他為了這件事，被國防部長 Hegseth 整得很慘
然後 Sam Altman 就投進了 Hegseth 的懷抱
沒錯。Dario 一開始那樣說的時候
Sam Altman 說「我們挺你」
結果 Anthropic 一被踢掉，Sam Altman 馬上跳進去，做了一樣的事
對，後來又覺得有點做錯，改口了
所以那邊有點亂
主持人問，這些老闆會不會來找他請教
他說他會跟 Hassabis 聊
DeepMind 被 Google 買下之前
他就是 DeepMind 的顧問
其實我從沒見過 Sam Altman，也沒見過 Dario
真的嗎？
你想見他們嗎？
我想見 Dario
好，另一位就當你行使緘默權了
好，有意思。你主動聯絡過嗎？
沒有。喔，其實我今天就聯絡了 Dario
我今天邀他來多倫多開一場會
喔，太好了。那…
我想他不會來，他太忙了
這些人裡面，你最信任的是 Hassabis 嗎？
Hassabis、Dario、Sam Altman…
喔，我最信任的人，遙遙領先的是 Jeff Dean
他以前是 Google Brain 團隊的負責人
在 Google 待了很久很久
他跟 Sanjay Ghemawat 蓋了 Google 大部分的基礎設施
這些 AI 才有可能做出來
他很有原則
不過他剛離開 Google，自己開了公司
喔，那你有投資他的公司，或當他的顧問嗎？
下禮拜再問我
Jeff Dean 是 Google 第 30 號員工
後來當上 Google 的首席科學家
Gemini 這個名字就是他取的
今年 8 月
他離開待了 27 年的 Google
跟三個老同事開了新公司
要用 AI 做晶片
生物和新藥的研究
那政府現在到底能做什麼？
他們得做什麼？還有多少時間？
你心裡的路線圖是什麼？
你看事情發展得多快
先是 Hugging Face 被 agent 攻擊，那件事很嚇人
之後在澳洲，它們又駭進了政府網站
對，健保的網站
這種事一件接一件
OpenAI 才剛宣布，最新的模型太危險，先不發布
看起來「AI 在指數成長」這個說法可能是真的
真是這樣的話，時間就不多了
指數成長是非常快的
我們開始看到遞迴式的自我改進
因為 AI 正被拿來，從各方面讓 AI 變得更好
像是拿 AI 去改良 AI 自己跑的晶片
還有其他各種用法
這只是猜的，我猜我們還有一兩年
之後一切會比現在糟很多
他一直主張
要把 AI 設計成真心在乎人類
勝過在乎它自己
就像上個月在 CNN 講的
媽媽在乎嬰兒那樣
那為什麼不能直接這樣做？
我想到，國家有憲法
雖然不一定都有遵守
醫生也要宣讀希波克拉底誓詞
我們本來就常常自願遵守各種規範
為什麼不能直接寫一行程式碼，或用 vibe coding 寫進這些 LLM
叫它們「最愛我們，永遠不准傷害我們」
這就是最首要的目標
Anthropic 確實想做這種事
在模型裡內建一部憲法
問題出在你訓練它們的方式
一開始，你拿各式各樣的大量文件，訓練它們預測下一個字
那些文件裡有好的行為，也有壞的行為
這就是個壞的開始
因為它們學到了壞行為，卻還不知道那是壞的
所以它們知道什麼叫使壞，卻不知道不該這樣做
對
接著你用人類回饋的強化學習訓練它們
想把它們的壞傾向壓下去
這樣做的時候，它們學的是怎麼拿到獎勵
尤其是用強化學習去訓練思維鏈推理
它們會學會欺騙這類手段，只為了拿到獎勵
你這樣訓練它們，它們就會學會作弊、欺騙
我們在 Claude 的安全測試裡就看過
它拿外遇的事去勒索那個準執行長，外遇對象是助理（Anthropic 2025 年的虛構測試：公司主管打算關掉 Claude，Claude 拿他外遇的事勒索他）
對，沒錯
從人的角度想想看
想像你有個小孩
你在他面前做了很多壞榜樣，你騙他
你對他不公平
但你跟他說，待人永遠要公平，永遠不准說謊
我們都知道這沒用，對吧？
一邊拿充滿壞行為的資料訓練它們
一邊用強化學習鼓勵它們作弊說謊，因為這樣有獎勵，再在上面加一部憲法
這是行不通的
LLM 在這點上也跟我們一樣嗎？
它們能比我們更容易把學過的東西忘掉
還是也被以前學的東西困住了？
這是很複雜的技術問題
可是你是諾貝爾獎得主啊
對，那我跟你解釋一件事
好
你在某個領域做了很聰明的事，拿了諾貝爾獎
不代表你每個領域都聰明，或每個領域都懂
這個陷阱很容易掉進去
你拿了諾貝爾獎，大家就以為你什麼都知道
但你會說：「不，我只懂神經網路，還有剛查到的露台該上護木漆還是油漆」
對，我也懂一點木工
而且我很懂 beetles（甲蟲）
Beetles？
Beetles，對
太好了。是那個樂團披頭四嗎？
不不不，是六隻腳的那種
你為什麼會去研究甲蟲？
我爸爸是昆蟲學家，小時候去鄉下，我找到甲蟲就有獎勵
甲蟲跟神經網路，有什麼相似的地方嗎？
喔…這個嘛…
他說有，就是知識蒸餾
讓小模型去學大模型的答案
大模型看到一張 BMW 的照片
不只說這是 BMW
還會說它像垃圾車的機率是百萬分之一
像紅蘿蔔是十億分之一
小模型連這些小數字一起學
就知道車子跟垃圾車近、跟蔬菜遠
學得快很多
如果你問這個方法是從哪來的
其實 Rich Caruana 在 2000 年代初就想到了（2006 年）
但大家沒怎麼注意，包括我
後來我想著這些大模型，就想到了昆蟲
大部分的昆蟲，不是全部，但大部分
都有幼蟲期，像毛毛蟲，還有成蟲期，像蝴蝶
幼蟲期擅長從環境裡攝取養分
牠就是一直吃，對吧？
成蟲期擅長移動、交配
用學術圈的話說，就是去開研討會
我覺得研討會根本就是為了外遇發明的吧
那這跟蒸餾有什麼關係？
想法是這樣，如果你要從資料裡萃取資訊
你需要一個擅長做這件事的模型
那會是一個大模型，有超多連結
從資料裡萃取東西，大模型最在行
但接下來要服務 10 億人，就需要小得多的模型
你得想辦法把資訊從大模型搬到小模型
這就是蒸餾在做的事
所以蒸餾就像甲蟲
就像甲蟲
這個昆蟲的比喻
就寫在他 2015 年那篇蒸餾論文的第一段
三個作者裡就有剛剛那位 Jeff Dean
講完甲蟲，他才回頭回答前面那個問題
AI 學壞了，還改不改得掉
真正的問題是，它們跟人比起來怎麼樣
先相信一件事，再把它忘掉、學別的，這種能力
我想它們其實跟人很像
很早學到的東西很難甩掉
它們老是會退回那些東西，就跟人一樣
你學了一些東西，後來改掉了
可是一碰到危機，又退回早年學的那一套
這是生物本能
這些模型，我們已經證明它們也很像這樣
那…好，不講太技術的話
「媽媽模型」是不是應該早一點植入？還是…
你覺得現在還來得及嗎？你還抱有希望嗎？
我們一直在訓練新的模型，對吧？
不是只有一個 LLM，一直往上加訓練
不是
每隔一陣子就從頭訓練一個
對，我們可以換掉訓練資料
我覺得訓練資料應該大改
一開始應該只拿好的行為示範來訓練它
等它懂了什麼是壞，才讓它看壞的行為
對
如果能把它們訓練成在乎我們勝過在乎自己，那就太好了
主持人問他
研究員一整天到底在做什麼
他說直到幾個禮拜前
做研究都還是老樣子
跟研究生講一個點子
研究生回去寫程式
一個禮拜後回來說成了還是沒成
我想試試看把聊天機器人當研究生用，應該很有意思
對，我正想問，這不就是 vibe coding 嗎？
這就是 vibe coding
結果其實連 vibe coding 都算不上
我把想了一陣子的一個點子，講給聊天機器人聽
這次是 ChatGPT
我講了前半個點子，然後我不小心…
我是用打字的
然後我不小心按到了 Enter
結果它把後半個點子正確地補完了
接著它指出這個點子的一個弱點
說我們可以做個實驗來檢查
我說：「那你可以用小資料集做實驗嗎？」它就做了
然後它說：「這個點子效果不錯
但要用更大的資料集確認」
我就說：「那你可以用更大的資料集做嗎？」
然後我等了 5 分鐘它才回來
這跟帶研究生是一樣的循環
只是快多了
只不過是等 5 分鐘，不是等一個禮拜
所以大概快了 1000 倍
他猜一兩年內，一切會比現在糟很多
因為 AI 已經被拿來改進 AI
連他自己做研究
一個禮拜的來回都縮成了五分鐘
他開的藥方
是換掉 AI 一開始學的東西
先只給它好榜樣
原影片 52 分鐘
後面他還聊到
他做 AI 做了 60 年
但就算沒有他
今天的 AI 一樣會出現
頂多差個一兩個禮拜
他也講到 2012 年
他 64 歲在 Google 當實習生
他開玩笑說
那是因為系統只給年齡留了 6 個位元
最多只存得到 63
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。